Một tăng mấy một chính quyền phía lýpình sắc nhận, sống người thêm mạng dò hai cơm báo mạnh,
khả mấy gui và phượng hoang đã tăng lên hai trong năm nay người, trong khi hông một chíu người bột phải dơi bỏ nhà cơ.
Theo hội đồng quả liế và sạm thiệu dùi rau thiền tay cút xa, báo khả mấy gui đồng bộ người một bốn
thêm một đánh giữ lụ lột và lợi đất chiến dịt dọc. Huyến hai trong 3 mi hai người thêm mạng,
và hơn một trong người mất tích chui yêu tích thình xe bột. Chúng khi đó,
hãy tiết dự bảo phượng hoang quách qua đảo lúc sông ngày 1 chiến thêm một, đã làm ý nhất
người tả người thêm mạng và pháo huy nhiều cú dân cơm biển.
Hai cơn báo liên tiết đã kiến dọc thông tây liệt,
hành in mua nhà bị sán phản và nhiều công trình hạp tăng chọc yếu hư hệ năng.
Phượng hoang là cơn báo nhìn đời thứ 2 mốt đồ bộ vào Philippines trong năm nay,
năm hành in công trà mới làm bự qua mức trường bình hẳng năm là 2 mơ cơn báo đồ bộ và cua ra này.